uh so last year we had our highest day
black friday was our highest day
almost two million dollars in that one
day
[Music]
are we ready to roll can we roll
bro you got to take that hat off though
i can't see you
all right i was just trying to i wanted
to wear a costume of swords
like a little bit more spicy you're good
like that i couldn't see your eyes do
you um
i uh
do you have an ice bath yeah i have a
cold have you not driven in our cold tub
so is it called cold plunge
yeah the cold plunger i have one too and
what is your opinion of it so far
i like it i like it i use it about twice
a week i use it monday morning for
coffee
it's basically my wake up thing and then
i'll use it wednesdays after a workout
uh what's interesting though there's a
book i think called endurance yeah i
love that and they basically love that
book
there's a book and i think what they
said was that scientifically it doesn't
do anything yes and so that's why i have
like a problem with cold plunge which is
the actual product is amazing like if
you want to be cold that it's a good one
it stays like 39 degrees all the time
but
it doesn't i'm almost certain that it
doesn't do anything and
some people say it impacts your brain if
it does anything but like there's still
even conflicting research on that
i think the big thing that i like about
it is that it makes me feel tough yeah
it makes me feel good it makes me feel
good about myself i'm like noah you're
not tough man you're weak and i don't
know i don't really have that self-talk
in my head but i go into this thing and
i was like
do 10 and then when i'm about to get to
10 i'm like you could do 15. and then i
just feel proud about how long you sit
and then i get out and i'm like
um
it varies maybe like a minute two
minutes dude i did five minutes at 39
degrees and it was incredibly painful
that's what it said online to do so i
did it and i was just like i was
legitimately in pain like uh like like
more pain than i've ever felt just
through exercise
how did you feel about yourself i felt
tough i felt i felt tough yeah so like i
understand why it works but i'm still
looking for like peer-reviewed research
that shows that it works and i've not
found it and so that's why i was asking
how you thought about your cold plunge
because i heard you had the same way i
got to jump in here because i'm i'm a
cold plunge spokesman they're the one
sponsor for my podcast so i gotta oh wow
for their honor here so the thing is
dude i'm telling you the cold punch
products we're both supporting it i have
it too but here's the thing
here's where you're wrong though the the
thing that you're right about is there's
no research that shows that it is
good for recovery and that's what
everyone says they use it for it's
recovery and it's just like not accurate
that it's it's actually better to use
heat therapy for recovery than cold
but like some of the brain stuff there
is like more uh research there as well
as like
um
some of the other benefits around um
like
uh mood and um like have you heard of
this brown fat cell storage stuff like
that
yeah but
it
yeah i hear you i think it kind of works
i'm still i still need to be convinced
i it's like it's like a workout the way
to think about it is like it's a workout
for your nervous system like it improves
a lot of stuff that way but it's just
not good for recovery
i guess i would actually pitch the
opposite sam and ben where lately i've
been really into baths
that's just like been my go-to so like i
have i throw i got these bath bombs got
a little cbd in it i'll light a candle
and then i'll either put on a podcast or
i'll read but that lately i mean men
especially men because women have gotten
they knew about this they just didn't
want to tell us
uh but like i literally just came from a
pedicure if men are not pampering
themselves look if you're working hard
i'm saying if you're like putting in the
work you're working out you're doing
stuff at the job like take a little time
for that r r man go jump into the pack
about it not relaxing at all for me like
i don't want someone digging into my
nails
gross can you see that red white oh my
god i did the i did the american flag
that's awesome i don't know it's
honestly it's fun we're living once on
this planet have a good time all right
let's talk about um you came on last
time i personally thought the episode
was only going to do okay i'm telling
you i got tons of people that dm'd me
ben says that people thought it was
pretty good i thought people thought it
was great but for this one awesome you
have a list of one two like eight
eight bullet points but there's a ton of
ideas here
um oh and we and also people criticized
me because i didn't introduce you so
this is noah kagan noah runs this
company he founded it and is now the ceo
of appsumo it's like groupon for nerds
it's quite large i think last time you
said
80ish million in revenue
uh mitchell just said you guys now have
165 employees that's amazing and
you also do a
uh content so you you have a sick blog
called ok dork which i've read for like
10 years and you have your youtube which
now has 250 000 subscribers i think
right
almost 300 000 man it's it's
unbelievable youtube.com it's
unbelievable
that's sick uh and i remember you doing
it years ago just like on your phone it
was kind of lame it wasn't lame it was
just like you weren't trying
and then like you started trying two
years ago i think right
yeah that was it was an interesting
journey when covet hit two years ago
i was just shirtless at home with my
iphone and i was like i just felt good
about what was going on and i felt like
i could help and so i just started
recording on my phone and uploading it
and so you know and all the people that
are listening to your show i want to
start businesses it's like
just do now not how you know something
mitchell i talk about which is just get
going so i just uploaded that and from
there now there's a team of
i don't know maybe six people will spend
about half a million dollars on just the
team this year and you know from just me
doing shirtless uh in my house talking
about how to get your business going
your confidence but uh the and so the
reason why you're able to spend while
you're able to lose money is because you
are you somehow it drives traffic and
awareness to appsumo which is like your
main thing but does the ad does the
adsense or the youtube ad at all cover
the cost
actually it just started so what was
fascinating and by the way a lot of
people know me because i worked at
facebook i worked at mint.com um so
that's a little bit of people heard
about me so this year let me just pull
up our stats right now so the first last
year we spent i mean i think around 400k
uh i can look how much we made so just
getting it going really
just getting it's an investment it's
like a lot of these things fortunately
we had appsumo as our our bankroller
last year on adsense we made 121
thousand dollars to 840 year one
in our year first hardcore year of
having a team around good that's really
good
it's surprising this year is actually
but here's the thing this is going to
blow your mind and i think this is a
really kind of good good lesson for
business
we put out 800 and i think 449 videos
three of them basically generated all
this money which ones
isn't that kind of crazy one that's sad
either a we suck at making videos
or b you know a lot of businesses you
keep going keep going keep going keep
going aren't all the channels like this
though
i think it's a lot of business like a
power law distribution it's like a few
things do a lot of the significance so
the three videos that made all of the
money the first one was i went and
knocked on doors in austin we just
released millionaires
we just released it but that came out
towards the end of the year
uh and drove a lot of our money uh
asking crypto millionaires how to invest
5000 bucks
and then asking nft millionaires how to
invest a thousand more or less those
three videos
uh
made us the year but and that was after
a hundred and almost 50 videos that's
crazy do you um
do you so do you think you're all
surpassed your 500 you think you'll
break even on adsense this year
yeah our goal is not that our goal is
around a subscriber growth but this year
i think we'll lose budget wise it looks
like we'll lose around 200 000
just depends how ads do but i'm
basically not not really optimizing
around that that's crazy i uh i did a
call with this lady who has a bunch of
youtube channels and she was telling me
it's um her and a six-person team i
can't say her name but she said that
they're doing a million dollars a month
in profit from youtube just youtube
yeah it's crazy just youtube are you
guys
i think the thing with youtube youtube
is slept on same i mean tick tock is
another one it's a different type of
audience
but you guys have upped your your
youtube game yourselves i feel like
almost every business out there or if
you are broke and you are in any country
in the world and you have nothing to do
this is the easiest freeze business
anyone can so i just signed up to
monthly.com has this course with casey
neistat uh did you see that so casey
neistat has a course where every day he
gives you a lesson on youtube videos and
i bought it for like 300 and i'm loving
it it is really really cool
what if what are some of the takeaways
well so it's only three days in and so
but like in the first or second lesson
he just walked around his office he goes
i'm gonna show you how i find cool
stories and he's just walking around and
he goes oh that's a cool idea you guys
hear that beeping that's a truck backing
up and that ruins like it makes it
really hard for me to record throughout
the day i'm just going to make a video
on that or he'll walk by
a guy selling fake louis vuitton purses
and he goes oh that's a cool idea let's
create a video on how to buy a fake
purse in new york city
and so he's just like walking down the
street coming up with ideas and you're
like look i'm gonna create these are
just small silly ideas but i'm gonna
execute them really well so in the next
series he's gonna show us how he's
actually gonna execute these small ideas
that is awesome kind of cool right i
love that you're still learning well no
i mean i i think people
assume that once you get to certain
sizes like you i would assume you don't
but i love that you're still curious and
you're exploring how to improve your
craft yeah well i don't know anything
about video i've been making videos for
my own youtube just for fun but i'm
trying to learn um so anyway it's a cool
cur it's a cool course it was only like
three hundred dollars
yeah i mean it is kind of crazy when you
think about the things we spend on and
the potential value upside you can get
out of it like the downside you lost 300
the upside i mean how much does this
make you or you know also from an
enjoyment level and i was like i can use
the stuff that i'm learning just in the
podcast i think
how much like what have you noticed or
observed in your own youtube channel i
know from my first million you
definitely you guys have been looking to
grow it seems like a few things are i
think what i've learned is that like
things that like don't seem like big
ideas but that can be kind of boring
uh can do really well so for example i
bought the house the lot next to me and
i just like film a video i'm like here's
just here's a video of the house and i'm
just walking around my iphone here's why
i think it's it could be a good
investment here's why it might be a bad
investment and i just posted that on my
personal channel and i didn't have any
subscribers oh i sent you that video uh
and it uh it got like three four five
thousand views but like a lot of
comments and i was just amazed that
people cared it was my first video i was
amazed that people care about little
things that are small that are part of
your daily life that you don't really
think about and so i think what i'm
learning with casey when i'm learning
with my stuff is that small stuff
that you think about throughout the day
more likely than not a lot of other
people think about that and they'll find
it interesting enough to to watch
you know what i mean yeah
yeah i've always i always think about
that with restaurants where they sell
their cookbooks
like people want to see what happens in
the kitchen and you'll be surprised what
people want to yeah so anyway it's a
cool course uh you want to talk about
mud water
i do in a second one other thing i'm
curious is what have you noticed because
i think i don't know this one cares
about as well what have you noticed
about the youtube channel versus your
tik tok channel in terms of the audience
and the growth and the oh so let me tell
you about the tick tock thing so i have
a tick tock but i don't actually like
post on it i mean i did once or twice
but like it has no views so we did this
thing i was texting you about this we
did this thing where on the podcast like
three weeks ago we said we're gonna give
five thousand dollars to maybe at least
one up to three people and it's gonna be
a combination of if we like your videos
and how many views they have and we told
people to go to our youtube chop up the
videos and post it so far the hashtag
that we asked people to use has gotten
30 million views in three weeks
yeah
30 million views sounds too easy go on
so
these kids it's mostly like these like
19 to 20 year olds like one kid in
college at michigan he um he's one of
the guys i just started talking to him
and they create he created a handle
called like mfm minis and he started
posting our videos and he like would
animate them and he has gotten multiple
videos over a million views and you know
fat fire
yeah i made a
podcast where i talked about how much i
love fat fire
the subreddit which i found through you
and he uh made a video about that and it
got so many views that fat fire made an
announcement on their subreddit that
said we've been overwhelmed with new
applicants or new subreddit people
and we got 30 000 people in one day all
from the tick tock video where where me
sam parr is talking about
fat fire
all right that's wild man so do you
think most people business used to try
to do this tick tock stuff no i don't i
not most but definitely some right now
of everything that i've seen it's the
fastest way to grow an audience
for sure without a doubt
yeah i guess i've always i've been
hesitant because the quality of the
audience in terms of engagement
yeah well it's not even just the young
right the young is the future to some
extent but it's like youtube i feel like
the quality of the people that are like
really into it and they're available
during your newsletter they want to
comment and i feel like dog is just kind
of consumption i think that youtube is
much higher quality i i think podcasts
like for a long time even though we like
my whole life was podcasting i was like
i would [__] on it i'm like this is not
that cool
and uh now i've changed because i'll see
i get recognized now like three or four
times a week and it's because they like
listen to my voice for 45 minutes they
like think that they know you and so
they built they people get kind of
intimate with you
so it's do you get recognized from
youtube
i got recognized uh yeah it was cool
yeah sometimes i love it man i mean the
whole part of the journey is that like
uh i would this weekend i went to a
squash tournament
the houston squash was hilarious
and uh it was because this guy watches
he knows appsumo.com he's watched some
of the videos and and i was i was during
the pedicure day was one of the guys
from our company
and i was like man that's why i do
social media to some extent like it
really provides a cool magnet and window
i don't know if the window but a way to
just like connect with really
interesting people yeah i think it's
awesome like even if it's that not money
like it's a great thing yeah i think
it's badass so i'm going to continue to
do it can i um
so basically noah has the sheet that he
sent me and it's got a list of a ton of
things can i just read off and ask
questions i actually want to ask you
about chrome extensions because
they're like i'm like nerding out on
chrome extensions right now have you
ever even made one
i've bought one so we have one right you
have one
so
on here so i tweeted out so this is a
mutual friend of ours by the way but i
can't say who it is
they were considering buying a company
and it was a chrome extension and it was
two people
who were doing 25 million dollars a year
in sales
with their chrome extension
um it's pretty crazy and then grammarly
you know grammarly
yeah grammarly i think is like a 20
billion dollar company at this point
graham really does like 800 million in
revenue
that is what i like these sleeper ones
that people kind of just like don't know
dude grammarly is the best man it's
started by this guy named max who's i
think he's from like the ukraine and
he's a lives in canada and he's a he's a
hardcore engineer and i asked him at
hustlecon in the backstage like that
that they had they bootstrapped it and
they raised their funding uh they raised
a hundred million dollars at a billion
dollar valuation and i was with them
backstage and i was like dude that's
amazing so you're like almost a
billionaire now he goes yeah it's pretty
cool like the business is way bigger
than than no and he like he like smirked
but he was real low-key he's like yeah
it's cool the business is way bigger
than most people realize like it's going
to be huge
uh and it was awesome so grammarly is a
good business what what's your chrome
extension
leo.io
so it's kind of similar to that momentum
one which i think is pretty popular it's
the main one when you open up a tab it
has like a nice background
i think taking a step back on these
chrome extensions i think what's
interesting
um
about your tweet which was like this
chrome sensor make 25 million or these
is what are things that not everyone
else is paying attention to that you can
acquire for not a market rate like i
think ultimately that's how you can have
a lot of success in business but that's
specifically for for marketing a lot of
what i look for um so when we launched
sumo.com i actually bought probably
about five million installs i think give
or take 500 installs of wordpress
plugins
so i bought like some of the most
popular wordpress plugins around oh wait
which ones
uh i mean i have to pull up our list now
but the biggest one was google analytics
so it was like a million person
yeah so is google analyticator uh we
bought wp fonts we bought a construction
page so basically would i use wp fonts i
used a bunch of those
yeah so we scraped the
the thing that it's not just copying
this because now people are more aware
of it
but what you're looking for is like one
can you get structured data so we went
to the wordpress directory and you could
get all their rankings so i got all the
rankings and then i sorted it by ones
that were not updated recently so i said
which ones had the most installs that no
one's taken care of
and i would just email them and say hey
you haven't taken care of it i'll pay
you for it and because there's not a
market for it you can get a cheaper
price and then i just sent a blast email
to a lot of these people and picked up
millions of installs and that drove a
significant amount of zuma.com did you
even pay more than six figures for any
of them
for the google analytics one they had a
million souls i paid 100k wow that's
crazy isn't it that was the most
expensive one i i could pull up my price
could that could that google so for the
people are sending wordpress if you
don't use word i mean wordpress is used
by like three-fourths of the internet or
half half of like the top 10 000
websites and they have this like crazy
database of all types of apps that you
could plug user or plug-ins it's amazing
and sumo was a email capture plug-in
yeah i found our list we had a lot of i
bought all-in-one favicon just a bunch
of random ones um and then we would
rebrand them and then cross promo to
sumo.com within wordpress um and i was
thinking i would do the same and the
thing was is there there's not like
um these websites where people are
buying and selling them and a lot of
these guys weren't monetizing it was
just hobbies
and so i think in marketing and business
you got to look for something that's a
problem that other people haven't
identified and that's also why i bought
the chrome extension i bought it for i
think 20 i bought it for 25 000 for 40
000 installs
uh active installs on chrome but with
that one we could not monetize it at all
we tried like paid features we tried ads
to it we tried to grow it uh and we were
not as successful so i pretty much lost
almost all the money on that one how
much what's the cpm on ads for chrome
plugin do you know
i don't remember what it was but it was
abysmal
and
it wasn't something that we were able to
grow dramatically like i thought we
could like the wordpress stuff was
really cheap like we were getting that
stuff super cheap back that's crazy
there's this guy like i think there's
this guy who i bet you know who you
definitely know i think his name's
what's his name syed uh his last name
starts with the b
and he owns this thing called awesome
what's it called it's called awesome
corp or something
he owns wp beginner he's like the
wordpress underground mafia he owns a
lot of wordpress blogs let me explain
the story the story that i know it as so
basically he's only he's young he's i
think he's from pakistan and he's only
like 28 or something or 29 and he
started this thing called wp beginner
which is a wordpress
a site on wordpress so if you like how
to install blank on wordpress he'll show
up number one it gets like five or ten
million uniques a month a ton a ton of
uniques a month and using his blogs he
would see which plugins would get the
most install so he would say like here
are all the best like uh forms for
wordpress or here's all the best like
font plugins for wordpress and he would
just see which are the best he would buy
the best ones and then just promote him
extra hard on wp beginner and at this
point
i bet you he makes 50 million dollars a
year in all of his wordpress stuff
i wouldn't be surprised i mean i love
these industries that like everyone's
sleeping on
like i think the that wordpress stuff is
really interesting it probably is still
a decent category what's fascinating
though is the other side of the sam so i
actually try to do the same strategy in
shopify apps so i went over to shopify
and we were launching sumo.com on
shopify and i was like man i'll just go
buy all these people over there uh what
was interesting was that a lot of the
people on shopify were a little bit more
savvy and they had recurring revenue so
they were like we want 10x the price
where like 10x price of their revenue
where the wordpress plugins they weren't
really making money so i was like hey
i'll pay one cent for every active
install you have so i was getting them
for very very cheap
but the shopify ones like i couldn't i
literally couldn't buy almost our friend
andrew wilkinson bought a couple of them
and he rolled them up and eventually
took it public and it currently it's in
it's public on the canadian stock
exchange right now probably for 600
million dollar market cap it's called we
commerce
and they do like i think 30 million
dollars a year in revenue just off
shopify apps
the shopify ecosystem was interesting i
mean it's interesting if you can create
something really easily and other people
can copy you really easily
um
and then you don't control the payments
it was a whole wild experience in there
because shopify controls all the money
you don't you have to wait for your your
grandpa to give you your nickels
uh and they control the whole the whole
thing so we were like let's get the hell
out of this world but yeah we commerce
looks like uh 535 canadian which is what
like 100 million americans no not that
bad
yeah like what's the conversion of
monopoly money to usd
no i think it's i think it's almost
one-to-one um what uh
so are you bullish you're into chrome
[__] chrome plugins
i've pulled no i'm not as excited about
that i think what's what's interesting
is like what are the areas that are
either super early on
uh that like savvy people haven't gotten
into so like for example one of the
older stories for me was facebook news
feed ads
so look for these ad channels or places
that not a lot of people are like kind
of all paying attention to when newsfeed
came out no one was doing it and we went
bonkers on it and that was a huge driver
at appsumo for a lot of our growth
because it was just so much cheaper
because not everyone
if you're paying if you're playing in
the market you're going to pay market
rate and that's not how you're going to
what did you use to get clicks for on
facebook
oh man let me pull it up pennies or um
yeah i mean i wouldn't say it's pennies
but it's definitely like dollar email
subscribers and then like low 10 figures
for paying customers and now i think
appsumo would have to pull up our
dashboard but i mean i think we're
paying like 60 dollars for a paying
customer now it's so expensive when we
start so we got to like 200 000
subscribers just through blogging and
then we started doing paid marketing and
i think we paid a dollar fifty uh when
we sold it might have been like four
dollars and if i had a guess now i
wouldn't be surprised if it's six
dollars to eight dollars
yeah i still think there's opportunity i
mean the opportunities are always there
it's just like you have to be creative
you have to look so like for me i was
thinking about this recently like if i
was trying to grow a newsletter um i
probably would go try to sponsor like
super micro people on tick tock and
youtube like these guys that are guys
and girls that are like sub 10 000 subs
like
like if your your channel has like 966
subscribers like you'd be a perfect
person because you have like an engaged
audience you're super smaller you don't
know how much money you're supposed to
be making and the fact that i'm giving
you attention
um it's kind of like what i did at
mint.com we've done this with appsumo
mitchell on our team is doing it with
appsumo currently
i think that's still a really affordable
way let me ask you a creative way to get
a lot of let me ask you about mit so min
you were like the one of the first hires
there right
yes number four and min eventually at
the time it sold for like 120 million
dollars or 200 million dollars something
like that right
yeah one second and at the time that was
considered massive it's still a lot of
money but like particularly then it was
like it might as well have been a
billion
and
i loved mint it sucks now though like i
don't like man totally why what would
you do differently if you were running
the show now
oh wow i mean aaron was running the show
to be clear and he was really impressive
i got to give him props when he started
it and i want to talk about this because
i think your audience i don't know i've
been thinking about this a lot i think
it resonates with your audience aaron
worked alone
in his room by himself for six months
building a prototype
and then came out and convinced the
world to come check out this product
and i just have a lot of admiration and
respect for people like him like we have
an intern george he's living in my i met
him he works didn't he yeah he's working
from miami or sorry from hawaii to live
in he was living in another room his his
desk was an amazon box
right now his desk is my washer and
dryer that's awesome right and he's like
i mean
the point is i think with aaron patzer
as well as you know these people as well
as myself i was living on floors look at
my aunt's basement there's something to
be said for like the sacrifice and the
the dream
and i have a lot of respect for aaron
and george and you know even back in the
day with where i was at uh getting all
this stuff started
uh with mint
i think i mean look at how big some of
these these finance look at plaid right
so we used another company before plaid
was ever a thing and platt is now 10
billion i think some of the stupidest
companies that are big that i i don't
get is like brex
or ramp they're like credit card branded
companies they're like 10 billion
dollars why don't you understand that
it's pretty simple they just convince
you to sign up for their credit card and
they split the one percent fee with
mastercard on all your spending
i know but the fact that that's a 10
billion dollar industry i mean it just
kind of
it doesn't seem like there's a lot of
value add but it's almost similar to the
mint thing which is they took a product
that existed which was this bank
information and they they printed it up
um so i think mint could have been a
much larger role the vcs were definitely
disappointed when mint sold out
um i thought mint was gonna sell for
that price that's why i left early why
why did you think it was gonna sell for
that price
um
i thought the vision for it's always
interesting to think about people's
visions like mark's vision at facebook
was always this big
and it's interesting to see different
people and like how big they're thinking
and aaron thought big but it was like
hey we're gonna sell credit cards and
we're gonna sell people turbo tax
and i was like okay this at best
scenario is gonna sell for half a
billion
just in terms of how big that company
could actually be
and i just did the math to think about
well i own one percent so
max i'll get five million dollars
pre-tax which post tax means i'll get
two million and i was like i think you
know in in four years do i do i think i
can generate two million dollars for
myself and so i was willing to take that
bet did uh
that's that's kind of interesting
because i don't i don't think that i
think that big i mean i would say like
most people would think one
500 million is a pretty big exit what
would what would he have done
differently to think bigger i mean what
would a bigger example be
and so let me let me be clear i don't
care
like i don't care what people's visions
are per se and everyone should have
whatever dream they want like if your
dream is to make 5 000 a month or 500 a
month or i'm not hating on anybody's
dream
um it was just
i think there's look at how many how big
fintech space is today
right like plat alone just almost got
bought by visa for seven billion uh you
have robin hood which is whatever 15
billion so what mint did which was
really interesting was it acquired a lot
of customers really cheap
i think if they didn't sell out to
intuit as early there would have been a
lot of different avenues that they could
have parlayed uh this audience of young
people who are interested in personal
finance into a lot of different avenues
um at the same time though dude if
someone came to you and you're you know
you did take that you did take it which
is a good thing too like was he wealthy
you can make
no how old was he i mean he was
definitely educated but he had a chance
to
cash out i think he cashed out 30 to 50
million bucks
and i also i think he like moved to some
like remote area new zealand and he's
just living there now yeah well he
started like a
ambulance company like a software for
ambulances or something like that but
like aaron he's a creative guy he
actually tried to start a uh
a sky subway system that's crazy so like
in cities like in austin instead of like
having an underground subway it would be
an air-based subway oh yeah he's just
crazy creative like but look i think
everyone's got to figure out what it is
they want their own life to be like
there's no bad or we're selling out
stuff
uh
i guess lately i've been just thinking
about like with this one period of time
we have here on earth like how
interesting do we each want to make it
yes but i will to play devil's advocate
it's also
how hard do you want to grind so like do
you want to like because i think that in
order to make
in order to make cool [__] i can't
decide how i feel at the moment actually
for the longest time i was like dude in
order to make something huge and
something amazing you gotta just lock
yourself in a room for like three years
like you just have to grind now my
thinking is i think you actually only
need to do that early on and then you
can somewhat let up so where's your
opinion on that do you have to grind
like all the time in order to make
something happen or do you think that
you can you could have a little bit more
balance because if you have to grind all
the time that's just exhausting i only
have that so many times in my life
yeah
i mean
i don't know i guess i'm just trying to
think of different examples like for me
if you would have told me when i started
out sumo like hey no you'll be a
millionaire but it's going to take 10
years
i probably wouldn't have started
sure
and most of the people that i've seen
like one of my buddies is now making
eight figures as an investor
um it took him probably about 10 to 15
years to get to that place
and so the reality i was thinking about
today like there's one of our guys who i
we got pedicures today he's on the sales
team and i was like look you can be as
big of a life in a career as you want it
to be it's just like what path do you
want to take that on and are you willing
to to put in the work but i honestly i
think i kind of think the opposite sam i
don't i think of like what i'm doing
with appsumo on youtube it doesn't feel
like a grind like i'm actually like your
podcast what you're doing now does this
feel like a grind most of the time no
but it doesn't feel great all the time
like some days i'm like oh i don't feel
like being happy like i'm in a pit like
here's an example
shawn my co-host who's out with kovid
he's late every single time he's five
minutes late every single time
every once in a while it'll put me in
such a bad mood that i don't want to
record and on those days i'm like i
[__] hate this i don't want to do
this i gotta like snap out of this mood
and be in a good so anyway it's not
always fun
i i mean i think about my buddy adam
gilbert it's like the times that you
don't want to show up is when it counts
like i think about that a lot of times
when i'm like it's the things you're
doing when no one else is watching that
matters
and that's like going to the gym when no
one wants to do it or like last night at
7 30 i didn't feel like doing a podcast
um but i'm you know it was like okay it
needed to get done and i think that you
know that'll help you separate whether
you want to get some of the things in
life you want or not like are you
willing to sacrifice and for how long
and i think that i don't know i was
thinking about this equation like i
wonder if there's a time time sacrifice
equal success equation
plus a little bit of unhappiness and if
you could do that for some period of
time you'll get success i think um it's
it's the way that i the question i ask
myself is what am i willing to pay in
order to achieve blank
so like to me that that's like what am i
what i'm what's what price am i going to
pay in order to get to to this
particular goal and i ask myself am i
willing to pay that price and sometimes
i am sometimes i'm not
so like at the current at my current
stage in life it's do i want to grind
for a long time on a software company in
order to achieve x amount of money and
i'm like no i don't want to pay that
price at the moment maybe like in the
future i would and for sure when i was
younger i would but not at the current
point in my life
i think with all this stuff it's better
to be not to be naive and just get going
well just find the things that you're
curious about like if it's you know you
your your audio editor benji and be like
look i like making these audio shows i'm
just gonna go for it
or lately you know like i've been really
enjoying appsumo work um or doing the
youtube stuff and
it's better to just not almost not think
about it because i think you'll psych
yourself out like one of the stories we
were talking about on the sheet was like
this mudwater guy yeah what and this guy
just had like a dude this is a crazy
yeah i mean it's just it's basically
indian chai tea you ever heard of indian
chai
dude it's delicious i love it yeah you
have a really good video i watched the
video of you testing it out and i bought
it because of that
oh oh yeah cool and um i wasn't
sponsored it wasn't affiliated or
anything it was just this guy with one
product which i always find really
fascinating i think a lot of us get so
excited to have like 18 business ideas
but apple
uh a lot of other people uh are making a
significant money just with one thing
and so he was having it i think he was
at an agency
just a regular day job and i think
everyone should get a day job or get
some basic income
uh and then he i think what's
fascinating was what's a problem you
have and what's a big ass category
and like coffee is one of the biggest
categories in the world
and so i love that he kind of said all
right what's the angle against them
and he created his own version literally
i think buying products off amazon and
just mixing himself together how's it
going he's not like some coffee
what's that i think he's i mean last we
heard it was a 60 million revenue which
revenue is always different than profit
as i'm sure you you know
uh but it's just fascinating that he
found one product line
and did great branding and just really
went hard on 60 million is so much money
it makes 60 it does 60 million in sales
that's crazy
i wouldn't be surprised if it's more i
think what you know when you're thinking
about business ideas number one what's
problems that we have ourselves
that's always just like the easiest way
that i try to solve it for me like one
problem i had recently it was like i'm
trying to be a doomsday prepper same and
i want like a doomsday i want a doomsday
prepper in a box
like i just do bro we had a total
episode on that clearly you read tucker
max's article we had a talk i did see
his i had to see his article this is
this is a little bit before because we
had our snowpocalypse same and i'm
looking at generators already because i
know it's i'm afraid it's like yeah i
just got mine uh did
how much did you spend like a thousand
dollar generator
it was a thousand i'm thinking about
getting two dude those generators are
not that strong they only charge like
four things like they can only be used
on like four things at a time
i'm just gonna basically have a
generator to a tent and then when the
doomsday comes just like come knock on
my tent door dude i would love a
doomsday in a box i'm so on board the
problem is is that a lot of the doomsday
stuff they assume that you live in like
the country and i'm like no i need like
the urban version of this so like tell
me like how do i store water how do i uh
like like should i have a gun or should
i not have a gun what type of generator
what do you use the generator for all
that type of stuff
yeah i mean i think coming back to what
we're talking about it's like with mud
water and you know business ideas it's
just like one just go to the things that
you need help with
right and then just start thinking all
right well how you know how do i do that
today right so you if for this doomsday
idea i'd go hit up you i'd hit up
neville i'd hit other friends in austin
and say hey i'm starting to put together
a thing do you want something like this
and see if i can get anyone to buy into
it before i start and then from there if
that works then maybe launch a shopify
site uh or just start doing youtube
content around that yeah you just wire
cutter for the end of the world
honestly that it's a huge category
especially like nowadays like all the
stores are out i think people are a
little bit more aware that that can
happen we have this friend named ryan
dice and ryan dice started digital
marketer which is like a pretty sizable
business that does all types of stuff
and he owned a conference that he sold
for a lot of money but pre-pandemic like
two years before the pandemic he owned a
website called like survival something
oh yeah it was i forget what it was
called and had he who would have known
but had he held on to it towards like
covet times it would have been sold for
so much more because now it's so much
more popular but he had this website and
it it talked all about uh like article
it was basically articles and affiliates
on like which flashlight to buy like for
the end of the world and i'm almost
positive that he sold it for around the
eight figure range
that's
remember that site what was it called i
guess
i don't remember the exact thing
survival or something so i remember
seeing it i'm like oh that's shady me
too i thought it was just it wasn't how
i won it yeah
it wasn't shady it was just i didn't
understand it i think sometimes i'll
dismiss people or dismiss businesses
about that but i think coming back to
like business ideas and like one-person
businesses like
i was thinking about the crypto space as
well and or just all this stuff if like
you don't have money and you can't buy
it you can always just document it just
go review it like you said it's like
your idea be the wire cutter of these
different categories be the tick talker
or youtube or whatever that is
what's the best selling product ever for
appsumo
oh on the digital side dude i'll also
tell you another business idea i would
love for someone to start
um
i'm going to pull up our forever list
hold on i'm literally just i'm pulling
up our back end the top product of all
time and this is a shocker
probably five yes
or stickers
okay ben do you have a thought
i have no guess no nothing maybe fine
let me see
something involved with photos photos or
fonts maybe
there it is so our top sell ever uh so
last year we had our highest day black
friday was our highest day
almost two million dollars in that one
day on black friday which we paid out
half of that
uh at least half of that to creators
which is [__] wild
um
the top product
oh this is interesting top product was a
video editor
so a lot of video content so if you want
to get a video editing the second one
was photos
what i'm just looking at what are some
other interesting trends like oh wow
have you guys
do you ever invest in companies just
because you're able to look at the
appsumo stats
so that's something we've gone back and
forth here's another well taking a step
back i know a lot of your people want
you know to make their first million and
beyond here's another product category
tools for agencies
but if you think about what that really
is so i can't say the product because
it's his private numbers but basically
stuff to help agencies manage their
project management
um but the real thing well one of the
things about
what's a tangential bit what's another
example that you so like um
so like like basically asana for
agencies
yeah like click up
like something like a click up like a
click alternative we have a lot of that
on up soon but anyways the point that's
interesting about that is and this is
this actually surprised me when i came
back to work at appsumo was what are
things that you can sell to help people
make money
well our friend neville
uh has says a slightly different he says
well because neville has a course and
he's like well i sell this course and
people like it but like really what i'm
learning is like when someone gives me
money for a course i'm just putting them
to work and if you really wanted to make
a lot of money i would just do the work
for them and charge them
[Music]
and that's how we explained it which is
similar but uh so what are some of the
other top ones on appsumo
yeah i'm looking them up so dude the so
one photos stock photos is a sleeper i
i'm shocked at how many people want like
stock audio stock photos stock video
secondly is video editing which if
you're not technical that's probably
harder to do this is this is the area
that like
this blew up a lot last year and it's
still going which is all this gpt 3 auto
content stuff so auto ads auto writing
um
so like copy dot ai alternative i'm an
investor so we promoted writer
happyscribe
um
i'm looking up the other major ones
around that
those are just some of the ones that i'm
just like shocked at how well they've
done but i mean i think cool part about
sumo and like people check it out is
like there's a lot of new products that
you honestly can just check out what's
getting popular and then make some type
of alternative or make training around
those types would you ever invest in
stuff based off the appsumo data oh
um
you know i've actually invested
differently so we've talked about this
over the 11 years of the company like
hey they're doing well instead of us
taking a split of the sales what if we
took equity instead
um and i would have liked i mean dude
think about this we've promoted hoppin
they're eight billion dollars we
promoted udemy mixpanel optimizely
mailchimp fresh i mean if we took some
splits it would have uh
be a different trajectory for our
company but it's just not something
we've done
uh i do it differently i invest in the
companies uh that we use in our company
sure like uh so like uh like what
atlassian i went and invested so when we
were building shopify apps five years
ago i was like i don't know if our
shopify apps are gonna work but i'll put
ten thousand dollars in shopify stock
when it just started so if our apps suck
i think the shopify thing will probably
work and that shopify stock now is like
60k
um but atlassian hubspot i bought a lot
of hubspot stock once we started
transitioning a lot of our team to
hubspot but i think what i just think
about is like where do i have an
advantage or understanding that other
people may not
yeah i how many products have you guys
promoted on appsumo like hundreds or
thousands
thousands i mean we've been 11 years i
think right now on appsumo we have 11
000 products um
yeah it's definitely gone a little wild
uh has become a software marketplace
that's crazy but uh 10 493 products so
when we um like years ago or a couple
years ago we had zoom was one of our
advertisers and this was before they
went public
and the ad crushed it it was so good and
we were like damn dude people love this
product they love zoom and we ended up
buying stock right before or
right at ipo and it like knocked it out
the park i think there is like
interesting stuff where you can where
you can see like in you you can see
interesting information because you're
like wpbeginner because you're like
appsumo because you're like the hustle
and you can see inside of the stuff
yeah it's like and for everyone out
there it's like where do you have an
advantage like where's maybe you're in
discord all day so you know what the
nfts are going to be popping maybe it's
going to be out there on twitter world
so you know like the different stocks or
different people that are talking about
different things i think just finding
some advantage or like area that you can
get uh
you know an unfair competitive advantage
what other ideas interest you
i'm trying to think about just like uh
the stuff lately i mean that's
interesting is basically like three or
four areas one i mean i still think
software is gigantic what specifically
there's just so many what specifically
um
i mean for me content creation is
definitely the area that i've spent a
lot of time in so like i would love
software on like how do you figure out
which topics are gonna be popular
like we spend i don't know how many
people hours probably like 10 hours a
week
just to figure out which video to make
each week
and so there's got to be a more uh
optimized way to do that i think with
appsumo it's the same kind of idea like
we have a team of i think around four
people that full-time just try software
all across the internet what their only
job
yeah they're they're called like ldrs
like
i don't even know what their titles are
anymore they don't tell me uh but their
little job is like go to product hunt go
to google go to twitter go to all these
like beta lists go to all these
different sites try the different
software all across the internet and
then see which ones are worthy to get
you know blasted on appsumo.com and so
that that feels like that should
actually be a software solution so i
think a lot of it is just like what are
the things we're doing manually that we
could automate so for me topics is big
finding products for appsumo is big
um i'm super excited about you know i
think a lot of people are crypto space
so
uh one of the things i'm looking for is
like how do you scrape
twitter and reddit and find the new next
thing before everyone else so kind of
like a google trends or like a discovery
thing for these crypto nfts how do you
do that now
i don't got it i mean it's just too hard
manually right now what i do is that i
text my friend who basically just spends
16 hours a day doing nfts i'm like which
one are you buying so like a few days
ago i bought a hippo
that'll work did i tell you about i
bought i bought a five thousand dollar
was it how much was it
i spent on that
i think i said no it's only almost two
thousand dollar hippo but it's part of a
casino
so if you as the casino makes money if
you own one of the nfts you get a cut of
the casino rake so sean it feels like a
scam john created an email list the
other day and he called it the milk road
and
i don't know
i don't know if it's daily or if it's
weekly but sarah's been getting it and
loves it and it's all about crypto and
he tries to talk about like the latest
and greatest from a trustworthy point of
view and it's it's pretty great the milk
road is awesome that's a great idea
the milk road what is he recommending i
haven't read it yet because i don't like
crypto but sarah's been reading it and
like he'll just say like people are
tweeting out like so the weird thing
about crypto and nfts is like it's on
twitter it's like in uh groups that like
you have to be like on the inside to
know what's legit and so there's like
these like stupid discourse groups dis
uh discord groups and uh
like these weird tweet twitter folks
where you gotta like know who to follow
and he'll be like blank is tweeting
about blank that's interesting because
of and then he'll explain
and so it's kind of interesting i think
what
i think was interesting about a lot of
these side hustle ideas and we put
together like top ones around crypto if
you're poor meaning like if you want to
be in a crypto but you have no money
like there are a lot of ways to do it
uh and one of them is just documenting a
lot of this stuff
right like you could start a newsletter
just like researching and putting out
like hey here's things that are
interesting that i'm seeing about it
and eventually that's how you do become
an expert in these different areas how
many the other go ahead
no how many coaches do you have in your
life
oh right now
uh not as much so i have a ceo coach so
there's a guy i've been working with
named ken coleman out of the bay area uh
what's what's this
is that torch or is it he's just an
independent so ken's like old school
like he's not tweeting he's not on
youtube uh he's just been around silicon
valley in a lot of these different kind
of companies
and a lot of his stuff is very like um
like really obvious euphemisms like
leaders noah leaders lead
basically
yeah he's great man he's great uh who
other coaches and then i have like a ceo
advisor so this guy named raj who works
at indeed he's phenomenal he's a little
bit more operational so i go to him with
different people that were
um i'm like yo here's things i'm seeing
today what do you think i should be
doing about it and so him i have a
hebrew coach right now i'm looking for a
squash coach
i've been really getting into squash
it's actually that's kind of been a
harder coach to find so i um you like
you've always been into coaches and
you've always done less i've always done
lessons and so like you've always you've
always had like flight lessons or like
oh yeah i think you used to do boxing
and so after we started boxing's on
friday so after i talked to you i
started hiring coaches and coaches are
pretty sick so i've got a bunch of them
now and they are badass it is absolutely
upped all my most all my coaches are
fitness related but like if i do want to
learn something i always hire a coach
now it's 100 the way to go
dude i'm glad that's cool to hear that
man so you have your fitness coach well
for your box i have like a boxing yeah
and like we
like and so he's because i'm like trying
to fight and like prepare for a real
match and so he's like helping me and
then i have a fitness coach as well and
then for a little while i did my body
tutor but i have a different
nutritionist now so yeah i like i'm all
about coaches
i think where for people especially if
you don't have money to do something
like that it's it's more also like how
do you get someone to hold you
accountable
right at the end of the day like one of
the things that i've found really was
just having an accountability buddy so
if you're trying to start a hustle if
you're trying to be healthy
um if you can't afford a coach like
that's an easy way to find someone to
just help you make sure that you you're
going on your bed what do you use like
maybe it's in your the hustle facebook
group what do you use to track all your
all your stuff that you have going on
like you have two or three or four
coaches at any point you've got your
work you've always got [__] going on do
you have some weird way that you track
all this
i track all of it i think the
i mean i just have most of my stuff is
just automatic
so i don't really have to track it
meaning that like every friday like my
calendar is is pretty much
as automatic as possible and i think
i've talked about this in the past like
it's coded
right so every friday at 10 a.m is
boxing so that's just automatic and then
generally flying
is going to be every other week and
that's yellow so that's one of my
learning and then hebrews on thursdays
therapy is wednesday every other
wednesday at 11. that's yellow so yellow
is my learning category
i do squashy steamy where we play squash
and go to the steam room uh that's not
really with a coach but i think if you
can have more things on autopilot so you
don't have to think about it then you
don't have to track it the only thing i
think i actively aggress not
aggressively but i've tracked for 15
years as my personal finance what do you
use so every single
i use a spreadsheet everywhere if you go
to i think on
yeah okay door.com where's my money
uh it's literally just like what's my
assets what's my liabilities uh and then
what are some action items i want to
take in the next 30 days do you when
when you're tracking any of that do you
count privately held stock as anything
um and then we can talk about appsumo
kpis because there's some interesting
stuff how we track there and then the
youtube tracking so more business
related stuff
um
in my network sheet i only track the
cost basis
so i don't track like how do you have a
valuation
no no so i'd literally just track how
much i invested in it so i invested in
like circle
invested in buffer just an lmnt
huckberry
um i only invest in companies i use i
don't invest in anything i don't use um
and so i just tracked that like i put
ten thousand dollars in and that's just
what it is i don't track like the
appreciation on that at all buffer's an
interesting company so buffer when i was
when so a lot of people who listen to
this show are young when i was like
younger when i was younger when i was 24
25 buffer was the most badass company
because they did this thing where they
revealed all of their revenue and at the
time that was like revolutionary um like
some small-time bloggers were doing it
but buffer started doing it but their
company has totally stalled hasn't it
like their revenue that's a tough one
like 25 million every single year for
like the last three years
yeah i invested them because i love leo
i love joel they're i mean they're very
innovative at the time i think what
people don't give like zuckerberg and
some of these people credit for is how
do you stay relevant and consistent same
with tim ferriss like how do you stay
relevant for 15 years
it's very easy to come out hot
but to actually kind of have that stuff
um how does zuck do it you know for
anyone out there
well i think for anyone it's just like
you have to stay consistent with it and
you have to kind of keep staying on that
edge of where you're a little bit
uncomfortable um i think with buffer
there's they basically my my guess is
that they hit a market saturation of how
valuable that is for people to pay for
their tweets yeah i'm looking at it like
maybe it's not as valuable it's gone
down since 2019.
yeah i mean i think they have here's the
interesting thing
they've gone down but canva is a 40
billion dollar company and it's pretty
much the exact same thing canvas canvas
is the same thing as buffer are you on
drugs what are you talking about canva
is amazing canva
it's the same thing it's how do i create
content that i can then share or post in
other places but i think where they
evolved past buffer which buffer was
like i'm gonna help you make your
content for twitter twitter or facebook
which really didn't make a difference
and then canva was like well what if we
can help you make these templates that
you can just use in social media but as
well through a lot of other categories
and so i think that's kind of like
market size is where they i think
iterated better than but not iterated
but picked a better market same as
appsumo we got lucky with this one canva
is going to be software canva is going
to be one of the most valuable uh
publicly traded companies i think in the
world when they go public
dude have you seen their numbers they've
just crossed a billion in revenue and
it's like doubling
really
canva is killing it man they've raised
money at a 40 billion valuation because
they grew their revenue from 500 million
to a billion in a year
and it's on a tear man canvas amazing
that is bonkers man
what's crazy is the founders are husband
and wives and they bootstrapped it for a
long time and so the husband and wife
trio or a couple is worth like 15 or 20
billion dollars right now good for them
it's not good canva is a crazy story
we're gonna have to cover canvas last
time because they're growing like a week
i have no idea how they grow so fast
one one thing i did want to come back on
sam i was talking to mitchell on the
back end um one thing i do in tracking
that when i've told people i always find
it pretty interesting is like i do
monthly life and reviews
i told you about this every month
yeah it's actually been i mean it's kind
of dude so every month and this i've
done this now for about seven years
um
and it's basically an email i sent to
tynan nick gray and my buddy jimmy and
leo and you basically just review your
past month and you i actually started
sending it to like my brother my buddy
johnny and a lot of a few other close
friends but it's pretty fascinating to
track what's happened in a month and um
it's been fun to go back super like
years ago to see what was happening in
my life but it's also interesting to be
like okay look at all the photos from
the month what happened in the month
what can i understand about myself and
then what do i want to have upcoming in
this in for me january what do you but i
think that's been one so what i'll what
i'll do reveal in that email i'm going
to copy that so you you have yes
so i don't share my photos but basically
what i'll do is i'll pull up my photos
uh from december look through december
to the end and i'm like damn a lot of
hap a lot of stuff happened versus what
i think happened
um
i'll start the so let me just start the
december one i put december was a
[__] month uh six out of ten
um
it may not be my greatest but maybe it
was actually better than i think
and then i'll start the email with what
are the things i said i was gonna do
december and how did i do against them
so a few of them was like at peace with
my drinking
uh
and my
i was not at peace with my drinking i
said i'd go to a niners game which i did
um
lock in my 2022 bucket list which i did
and then i'll just try to do like a
little bit more of a stream of
consciousness reviewing of how the month
actually went about themes
work travel family i've tried it with
categories and i've tried also just free
flowing there's not whatever works for
you i think the important thing here is
having like a group of people that you
can send it to that don't even have to
give you feedback like they don't you
don't need their opinion but it's just
like here's my life how's your life and
if you want opinions you can ask would
you ever make that point and also
this is way too raw to make public it's
like
um such good content i would love to
like the research oh this i mean i'll
send you i'll send you the december one
just don't share it but it's just like
well i'm just saying like i'm i'm
thinking like would i do that as a blog
it's pretty cool the end of year reviews
for a lot of people the reason why i
started thinking about syed recently
that guy the wp beginner guy is because
he has this end-of-year review and i
always love reading his end-of-year
review
i didn't really i'll look him up um some
of this stuff has like we did this like
wild therapy out in mexico on the beach
which was just like psychedelics and
that
some of this stuff is just really
sensitive uh
yeah i don't know if i'd want to make it
public i'll send you let me ask about
that really quick and then we'll wrap up
but did that stuff make a difference
just don't doing psychedelic therapy
which i don't i told a story about how i
almost did it one time but i got kicked
out of the group
did it get kicked out
this lady
used to work at lehman brothers
she was like worked at the banks that
like helped destroy america at one point
and she got mad at us for talking about
money too much and like she was saying
how like her medicine needs to be free
for the world but was making me pay two
thousand dollars and i was like lady you
realize how like country or how like
hypocritical you are like you're talking
about like how capitalism ruins
everything but you're like you worked at
lehman brothers and like you're making
me pay you two grand to do drugs with
you like come on like don't act like
your [__] don't stink and she kicked me
out of the group so i didn't get to i
didn't get to actually do it with her
you couldn't have your self-improvement
yeah i didn't she didn't let me do drugs
with her
um i do want to and mitchell mitchell is
messaging me he's like yo you got to do
your favorite purchases or websites wait
but tell me really quick did the therapy
work
so i've done a lot of different therapy
like i've done ayahuasca which i put i
put that article out that went viral and
if you read that yeah i if i remember
correctly the takeaway was like it was
cool like it made somewhat of a
difference but like it wasn't that great
um
no it's definitely impactful it's just
intense i mean i think what you know
there's a lot of different ways to eat a
reese's peanut butter cup i always think
um the it was lsd therapy
and
um
i think the main theme that i took away
from that specific experience well a
theme in general for me is like how much
should we have life be super
predetermined like i want to go make
this much money or i want to go on this
vacation versus how much should we just
let the day like unfold
and uh i think that's where that was
definitely a theme i was trying to just
understand i think the big theme from
that specific experience was like how do
i let more joy in my life
right like my word of the year is smile
like i was gonna have an intent
yeah like to have an intent or something
there and for me smells just like yo i
just enjoy it right we're all gonna die
someday just like
enjoy the grind enjoy getting to chat
with you today which you know i was like
this is probably the highlight of my day
i have a buddy coming at 6 30. but i was
like i really want to talk to sam today
like i'm looking forward to it
um
so that was the main theme for from that
experience i think there's a lot of ways
to learn about ourselves i think you
know mdma or lsd therapy regular therapy
journaling there's a lot of different
ways you know whatever is calling people
at the right time what are your uh all
right mitchell was telling telling he
also told me this or he wrote it in the
thing about best stuff to buy for under
a hundred dollars you and i are the same
in that we buy lots of crap just because
like we're up we're both obsessed with
gadgets
um by the way you sent me over so i told
noah's gonna go camping and he sent me
over this massive tupperware container
with like all these gadgets there was
candy in there that expired in like
2012.
like i went camping is any of the
gadgets in there
yeah i went camping and i used your
lantern and i used like one of the
flashlights and a headlamp and uh i saw
i found some swedish fish or something
like that but it like expired like years
ago
i'm more of a sour patch kid guy now
that's what it was sorry it was sour
patch kids it was it was like it was it
was that type of candy yeah
um different purchase i don't know i was
trying to pull up some of the different
things that i've bought that i'm like
man i like these and i use them a lot um
the coal plunge i didn't buy it
it was expensive as [__] it was like
five grand um but in my opinion if you
want to be cold it's a pretty cool
gadget
i like it i just i guess the question is
that like i think retail is 5k i p so
this i think you'll appreciate this i
hit them up and i said hey i'm a social
media influencer which i find ironic oh
my god i i say it as a mockery i didn't
actually say that i was like hey i'm
interested in your product can i
actually just pay cost and then i'll
promote it because i figure like i want
to support them as a business so i think
for people out there that want to get
free crap like just pay cost you get it
a lot cheaper and you can promote it if
you like it
that's good um
i like it but i don't know is it worth
3k
probably not i like my i've been using
the bathtub in the hot tub a lot more
often yeah
come over here come on do a longer
workout oh dude here's the thing that i
think people are sleeping on but some
people are using it have you used apple
air tags i just got one they're pretty
great dude they're like secretly amazing
like i throw it in my luggage and in my
backpack so if it ever gets lost in like
travel or someone ever jacks my backpack
there's like a little secret tag in
there dude i've been using tiles for
years but the tiles are only okay the
air tags are what's the difference i
never use those just the interface and
how loud the beep is
oh that's it yeah
just that just those two things
they're pretty dude you can actually uh
i haven't messed with 3d printers too
much but tynan he puts out a dude
tynan's gear list if you don't check out
tynan.com's gear list definitely one of
the top gear lists ever like
t-y-n-a-n-com
so his gear list is awesome he has like
a lot of usb stuff and like what's the
smallest charger to be using
um but he what you can do which is crazy
on etsy this is a really neat hack you
can buy a 3d printed thing where you can
put an apple air tag and then secretly
attach it to any of your bikes so if
you're a biker
for like 15 bucks you can buy a secret
thing that attaches to your water bottle
and no one will ever know it's there so
you have a tracker on any of your
expensive bikes oh that's sick but does
the air so the air tag only works so if
it's in within bluetooth of a iphone
of any iphone that i think that's where
there's a little bit of like controversy
but it's any apple device that's good
all right i think is the internet
connection or bluetooth mesh i think i
thought it was bluetooth
which is kind of like [__] up if you
think about it bonkers right
dude
well i mean there's these stories where
like someone put it on someone's car and
then they're tracking them home i think
that's obviously like that's messed up
um
but i think just the technically like
it's just a fun tool to start playing
with and just start experimenting with
all right so what else have you gotten
dude you know what i've gotten really
into tea
why i'm like i don't know man i've been
into like chinese tea
so i bought um
a snow peak bottle
it's called snow peak is the brand it's
like super
uh good for like travel and stuff and
then i buy um it's called a guy wan i
can't believe i'm talking about this
publicly i don't know just so nerdy it's
like what creepy white dudes do um
i mean you want these guy ones you have
like a little chinese tea ceremony and
it's really inexpensive you can go to
aliexpress buy it for like 10 bucks
um and i bought it a travel one actually
so you have one for home which you can
buy an aliexpress for like literally 10
bucks or from keith titanium you can buy
a guy one that's for camping that's like
200 bucks uh so when i travel i'll bring
tea around and i get it from this place
in the bay area called old waze tea
is that well yeah oldwaystee.com
that has definitely been something i'm
uh way more hyped on and i've definitely
been drinking a crap ton more tea this
year
um a good thing that i bought recently
which i'm almost positive you have as
well what brand chair do you have
i think this is an autonomous same we
have the exact same one so uh
so basically these chairs that i was
looking at they're like fifteen hundred
dollars like a fancy chair like are they
really an aeron i think it's called uh
it's like 1200 to 2gs
they're really expensive and so
autonomous is a new startup that's
making chairs and desk supplies and it's
basically as good i think as the really
fancy one but for like 350 bucks
yeah these are definitely affordable one
thing one thought i've had sam is like
what have you bought in your life that
you're like man this is luxurious
i was trying to think of things that i'm
like like i bought this levi's jacket
because it's getting cold in austin it's
got the little fur it was
89.
and i probably looked for a coupon and
i'm like yo this is like i look like a
cowboy like a real cowboy this is
obviously kind of a joke um and so i was
just trying to think like what are other
items in my life where i'm like man i
can't believe how rich i am even though
it's not that expensive and definitely
that jacket isn't exactly dude amazon oh
you have these
amazon basic moccasins i got those
because of you actually yeah they're
sick dude
those are 20 bucks i'm like i walk
around my house i'm like who's the king
who's the gig
i love that um one thing that we do at
my house is
we do costco socks
and we'll buy like 50 pairs
and just never match socks again and
then at the end of a at the end of like
half the year or so we just throw away
all the the socks and get new ones
because like if they wear out or if
because i i hate matching socks
and so
i hate you know like it's just stupid
why do i gotta like spend all this time
like putting them in a ball together
like just give me like a huge bin where
they're all the same and i'll just grab
two
it's stupid matching socks is stupid i'm
i i take a stand against that and so
anyway i just don't match socks anymore
and so that's my splurge is i uh i spend
like 200 a year and i just get fancy new
socks also another thing that i do
that's pretty amazing is i do the same
that same thing but with x aficionado
underwear so like you know like
dude you know when you put underwear on
and there's like a pair that's always
like the last to be used because like
the band is all stretched out or you
just like don't like it or it's like
stained or it looks ugly like you're
just done about it so i just threw all
those away and i only bought one style
one color but like 30 pairs and i spent
like 500 dollars to do it because x
aficionado underwear is like 20 to 25 a
piece
did i only wear saks underwear i think
it's the same kind of same kind of thing
but it's got the whole little ball
holder stuff yeah i like those too i
like sacks they're a good brand and they
don't stretch out as fast but they still
do wear out a little bit
i definitely feel pretty luxurious in
them do you ever mess with lululemon
socks yeah i'm all about anything
lululemon dude little lemon socks like
these no-show socks because they always
other all the others always get holes in
them i'm always just like frustrated
about that but the lululemon ones um
home what other stuff you bought they're
like yo this is rad and i do want to
spend at least five minutes i know we're
gonna end here um
i wanna spend five minutes like how do
we grow your podcast let's like
brainstorm
like i know something you're aiming to
do so let's do one two one of these
items and like i don't know well let me
all right let's do that now let me tell
you the numbers now
so in december we did uh uh right about
two million views
um i think or two million downloads uh
of which like i think 600 000 was on
youtube and the rest so 1.4 million was
just people going onto itunes or spotify
okay so what's your those are what's
your current goal do you have a goal
this year around the the audience or
podcast yeah
i think three three million uh
consistently getting at least three
million downloads a month would put us
in like the top like five business
podcasts in the in the country
what what's been the biggest thing
that's helped you grow it this is like
the way i'm just trying to brainstorm
with you what's helped you get the
biggest delta and new subscribers so one
of the shitty parts about podcasting is
that i've done a lot of growth stuff
it's been crazy hard to grow it and so
the biggest thing that's done well is
we've just invested more time and more
energy into good content so sean and i
like prepare we research a ton
our our chemistry has gotten better so
that's just like one big category of
just like improved content the second
thing that we've done that's starting to
work really well is we're buying ads on
other people's podcasts and so we've
learned this strategy from jordan
harbinger jordan harbinger has 15
million downloads a month of course he's
in like a big category it's just like
culture i think is the category he's in
and he basically spent nine hundred
thousand dollars in his first year
buying ads on other people's podcasts
and that's how he got big
hmm
okay um
you should sponsor okay my podcast or
i'll just put you i'm i mean you're
coming on next week for free
here's a question sure
yeah i mean how many downloads
did you get
i think it's about 10 000 an episode
dude so like
we're a little bit bigger than that now
but like just getting to 10 000 is
really hard
podcast do you agree are podcasts the
hardest thing you've ever tried to grow
that's why i backed out of it that's
when i went to youtube dude it's so hard
but it's super sticky like every podcast
that we launch is going to get at least
50 every episode we'll get at least 50
000 views i think
all right here's like one simple thing
that i don't know why you don't do on
your i think one of the ways to think
about one it's always easy to get people
to come from medium to medium so podcast
sponsoring means they come from one show
to the other super easier how come you
don't promote your podcast or newsletter
on youtube
well not so like
the newsletter but what do you mean the
podcast well no no so think about it as
like a gateway drug so
someone on another podcast is highly
likely to go to a different podcast
because you already know that they're
behavior-wise so sponsoring podcast is a
great one getting on other people's
shows is a great one
but you're getting like you had a video
recently where you got uh how i retired
over 20 million by age 31 had a has 140
000 views
but in the description there's nothing
that says check out my newsletter of my
podcast
yeah that's stupid we should do you're
right that's low-hanging fruit that we
should have solved for i would think
that's a pretty easy one and then
um
on your about page on youtube you don't
link to the podcast really
are you sure it says website well it
says website where does that go
yeah i mean i guess that's okay it says
website twitter instagram facebook i
might want to actually just put the link
for podcast
i would also consider i mean this might
be more of a stretch but i would
consider do you strategically try to
really intentionally grow youtube and or
tick tock pick one of those probably
youtube and then really think of that as
a way to get people into your newsletter
which is like the first step to getting
them onto your podcast no it's been the
other way around uh like lately we've
been going my first million has become
like almost its own brand i think yeah
here's what i think is gonna happen
i think in the future like in within one
to three years
me and sean in hubspot i think what
we're going to do is sell the podcast or
do some type of licensing deal
there's like no reason for me to think
this other than this is just like a
crazy prediction
i think that we're going to do some type
of crazy there's a world where we would
do a crazy licensing deal i'm hoping
that's a public company so i'm not
actually just so everyone knows i'm just
[__] guessing like i'm not this is
not based on anything
hubspot maybe would do a thing where in
three or five years we do some type of
licensing deal with like spotify or
whatever you know kind of like to call
her daddy uh podcasted do you know what
that podcast is call her daddy yeah so
they did a licensing deal for 60 million
dollars over three years
and i think there's a world where we
would do that uh with like spotify or uh
one of the other big public uh platforms
and i think that's i like that as a
creative at home but why did you say
getting people to
uh come on to your to to like grow the
youtube channel or tick tock it's not
worth it
or not as important you were like yeah
it's not good like what do you mean
there um i well what we've found is that
i think it's better to grow to send
people straight to the podcast because
if they if they click subscribe then
they're notified whenever there's a uh
four minutes
they're notified whenever there's a new
episode
you know what i mean
no yeah but don't you think like like
the amount of people available on the
youtube that are like hey i want to hear
more about this
then come on i mean think about how much
like joe rogan got found because of
youtube well and the second answer to
that is i mean we're trying it's [__]
hard if we're trying i'm like the
efforts if you look at our youtube page
look at our videos like
the effort's there like they just don't
get that many views all the time it just
it's taking a long time i mean how many
views look at our youtube how do you
think it's going in my opinion
recommendation do you want
recommendations yeah i would say it's
going okay
at best
okay so i think what you what you're
doing is you're uploading podcast to
youtube you're not actually creating
content that people watch on youtube
right so if you look at it at our
channel like youtube okay dork
the content is like made for youtube so
the two things that i would i would tell
your team here's what i would recommend
you to do over the next like three
months look at your ctr like the
click-through rate of all these
different videos and that'll basically
show you if you're picking the right
topics and then i as well your
thumbnails what's the baseline
uh if you can hit a five percent ctr
you're you're doing very well you're
doing very very well so like would you
say three to five is decent
i mean three is decent i think you want
to get to five you want to be like
hitting a really high number so like our
recent like uh awesome videos are
hitting five
um so i would i would basically just
start tracking your ctr your
click-through rate on these things and
the second thing you want to this is
just the the start with this stuff is
that i think this is a way of explaining
the pie that people find out about you
and then they're like oh in your
description about page go to the
newsletter go to the podcast which i
would just update your top 10 videos
here you don't need to do all of them
but do them moving forward the second
thing is your your average view duration
so the the saminaj one had it's a two
hour video there's a reason it got 26
000 views it's because it's long as hell
and i'm guessing your average view
duration was like 20 minutes how many
does that have 20 000
26 000 wow
where you know the serial killer got
busted through 23 me one i don't know
how that's relevant to people making a
million it's not put that on your own
channel
bro come on don't blame me for all this
stuff i've
you're who's in charge
i don't know anymore
well anyways i think the second thing is
just look at your average view duration
do the same thing just look at a line
graph so like how are we trending and
and don't worry about super optimizing
just where like each month or so can we
try to get both those numbers moving in
an upward direction
and the other thing i think you were
able to do that
what's that anything else we should do
i mean your your thumbnails aren't
really
i'm pretty sure we're using your
thumbnail guy
yeah it might be the thumbnail guy but
you're like how much are you actually
spending to make a great thumbnail so
like every one of our thumbnails now we
go and do custom photos so at 4 30 i'm
literally it's the third time going out
with a photographer to take a thumbnail
for the same video dude that's so much
work isn't it isn't that crazy there's
so much work to make it like a youtube
video i just dismiss it as like oh
you're just [__] around it's so much
more work than i thought
yeah to be good i mean i'm not gonna say
some cliche [__] anything great is worth
working do you feel like an idiot though
on the side of the street doing this
space where you're like hands on your
head and you're like freaking out about
the 2022 stock market now it's gonna go
down
well i think i mean the other thing with
no it's honestly enjoyable and i find it
kind of like a science it's like a game
where like it's a game where you in a
sense like how do i win this game and
doing that it gives me an advantage so
hell yeah i want to do it and i find it
enjoyable i think you know topics you
should also just kind of consider the
topics you're putting out on youtube
like how much do authors make
it's not something that i think people
are really like gonna immediately stop
and drop everything to watch but like
solana billionaires
right now crypto and nft and stuff like
that and how to get rich is always
popular on youtube
we're just like whenever we talk we're
just going to chop we just chop [__] up
so like it what we could do is like have
pre-planned topics that we think would
go get popular on youtube it's just a
little bit harder to do that naturally
in a conversation but i think we can do
it
but yeah our goal like i'm predicting
the future we're gonna get to like the 3
million range by the end of the year and
once there um i think we're going to be
end up being like one of the big i think
we'll be like in the dave ramsey tim
ferriss category inside the next year
and a half
here's a oh yeah we can end it one thing
i find fascinating is there's people who
are huge on youtube that no one knows
but a lot of people know who tim ferriss
is
kind of something i've just been
reflecting on what does that mean well
he's been in the game forever and he
also what entered the game when the
world was smaller so like in the niche
of like tech and startups there and and
this whole like make money online thing
there weren't that many people on it and
there weren't that many people who were
famous for it and he was definitely one
of the first that was famous for it do
you know what i mean
yeah i mean yeah that's interesting the
world gets bigger it's also getting
known your niche like i have a friend
who's popular in the spearfishing
category how about right i think
what's that he's got like few hundred
thousand followers on tick tock he's got
a full-time business now it's called
sick cast cast
it's called [__] group for nerds i
want to be a spearfish influencer this
guy is cool as [__] man if you ever want
to go spearfishing but i think what
fascinates me about him is like he's on
tick-tock he just does this you know you
talked about this in the beginning where
you documented your house he likes
spearfishing and he likes fishing and so
he just started videoing it put on tick
tock got like i think he's how many
followers you have on tick tock in
i think he's got like 200 000 cast and
spear 289 that 285 000 followers
he texted him yesterday i don't see his
revenue but he's got a you know not a
seven figure but a pretty healthy
business selling spearfishing gear now
i think instead of getting big at tim
where maybe people are responding i want
to be known or i'm an expert i've got
imposters and i'm just like do the thing
you're already excited about document
that and i think people will be shocked
that they can make a lot of money doing
it like my brother he does insurance
claims for hospitals are talking about
this no
so when you go to the hospital you get a
bill and the hospital has to fight with
the insurance company about how much to
pay yeah so he reviews the bill to
optimize to make sure that the the
insurance company pays the full amount
okay cause he can be like no they didn't
need to do this procedure they need to
do this and now he's so i think one of
the things is what do you have in your
day job that you can make a business out
of and so he's exploring how to help
individuals optimize well not optimize
but reduce their medical bills so if you
got a medical bill and it's like five
thousand or one thousand ten thousand
he'll review it for free
and then maybe take a cut if he's able
to reduce the amount of money that
that's actually a great idea there's
this company called buyer.co
and our my friend started it and it was
called negotiating as a service
and they would negotiate anything on
your behalf and take a percentage of the
savings
and the company sold to ramp so if you
go to buyer.com it redirects to that web
the company you said you don't like ramp
and uh it's not that i hate them there's
something to do and buyer
the guy he started he's like i sold out
too early but i didn't have any money
and it was like a cool way to make money
but um he was like i this could actually
be great i would do like a negotiating
negotiating as a service and have um my
health bill be one of the big ones uh
another great company is called do not
pay and they're doing this but for uh a
variety of different things oh yeah i
saw them i like do not pay
yeah do not pay the the robot there's
also like vendor.com
then there's like a similar one you give
me your bills they negotiate and they
just take a cut of whatever they see
dude i love those services i love
notebooks
win-win no one's down like quickbooks or
uh not quick in uh turbo tax mint
yeah turbo intertext a little it's like
oh it's free it's free it's free guess
what if you really want it it's paid for
they don't like but they don't take
money from you they just take a
percentage of your
refund
yes which i like yeah that's fair so i
did want to say though dude honestly for
your show because other people out there
are trying to do it i think obviously
you said go on other people's shows
podcasts
i think optimize these lower these other
platforms
um
we're going hard on the thing the
tic-tac thing definitely has worked
but has it driven people i think
ultimately is it helping me with my goal
is it driving people to the podcast
unfortunately i have no idea that's
another shitty part about podcast is
it's hard to know what works because i
can look at my charts and see how many
downloads we have it won't tell me
how they heard about us it's not like
google analytics where i can see like
the person who bought this came from
google because they searched blank on
this type of phone
have you done uh url genius
no we've done chartable is that the same
thing well url geniuses i think we use
this on our show sometimes it's
app.urlgene.us it's deep linking so
it'll link deeply into the podcast on
spotify i don't know if it does itunes
as well and then you could track i think
how those clicks are actually looking so
you can put that on tick tock or put
that out on the the youtube world
i didn't know about that all right i'll
look into that um all right samuel we're
gonna wrap up i love seeing you dude
thanks for doing this
you look good dude thanks for having me
did how many people reached out from the
last one it got ben messaged me he said
it got 65 000 or 70 000 views
really yeah
dude you guys are man
i told you the first time i ever came on
your show i had like an ex this girl i
went on a date with was like i can't
believe you're on the show yeah he
messaged me he said he got 65 000 views
or downloads all right i think this one
thank you for having me man this is
excellent all right we'll talk a little
bit talk soon
[Music]
you